and no one's gonna do it for you that's
the harsh reality that I learned five
years ago is that you know I got given a
phone and a laptop and it was like
sinkhole swim go and build a market and
see what you can do fair enough I didn't
make the business any money but I think
the difference for me was just my
attitude I wanted to do it you know I
had a real hunger in me that was like go
and get it I set myself some really good
goals and I think having a Clear Vision
of your goals and what you want to do is
so important I set a goal to do 50k a
quarter that was minimum like I had to
do that and I did it it's having
something to work for and being like
right well I know what I need to do so
we'll get it welcome back to another
episode of the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host his and on this
week's episode I was joined by Alicia
Birch from Anderson James group all you
need to know about this story is for the
first three years of Alicia's journey in
recruitment she build 20 grand in a year
she joined the Anderson James group and
back to back become their top performer
building over 200 Grand a first year in
over 300 Grand in the second year and we
dug into exactly how that happened what
changed and it was complete honesty I
absolutely love this conversation I
think you're gonna absolutely love
learning from Alicia enjoy the episode
Alicia welcome to the podcast I'm so
excited to be here thank you so much for
making the trip
love it now honestly thank you so much
um really looking forward to unpack this
journey that you've been on yeah it's
been wild yes it's been an interesting
and interesting one so just to to get
straight into giving everyone listening
just a bit of context so you've been in
recruitment for just over five years
yeah always in the same industry which
is
residential you've always done dual desk
but from what you shared to me it has
mainly been permed but then there's
might have been like 10 of your
buildings are being contracts yeah yeah
mainly so the last two and a bit years
you've worked to AJ
yeah with yeah with uh big James
Leighton that obviously he's been on
he's been on on the podcast
um and then before that you work for two
different brands but I think where
you've really kicked on has been the
last two two and a half years with with
AJ right yeah and I think I've got here
this is a crazy thing that I'm I'm
looking forward to digging into this
right so let's just get to it right so
before you join James and his business
your best year was 20 grand
this is the thing it's like I didn't
make any money for three years so I kind
of like write that part of my career off
like it never happened like yeah but I'm
Gonna Make You relive parts of it
unfortunately today
so so sat down with James he's like best
year so far Alicia you know everyone
you're well networked and like yep 20
grand
over it but obviously what you've then
gone on to do is hold the top performer
title in the last two years yeah
something to be super proud of sending
them off now yeah first year at AJ you
did 240 Grand second year
360. yeah and I think the split like you
said right pretty much 90 of that has
been perms and then 10 has been um
contract so and then now you are a
business development director in crime
the ranks and we're gonna dive into all
of that today so absolutely buzzing so
where we always like to to start is
million pound question so we'd love to
get your take on what does Alicia think
are the common characteristics and
traits that make up highly successful
recruit in today's market let's stop
there
is authenticity you've got to just be
yourself like you know there's a there's
a real for me I know there's people out
there that don't like me and I know
there's people out there that do like me
but I couldn't care less like the ones
that do like me and the ones that don't
you don't speak to and I think that a
lot of people in just in recruitment in
general is so bothered about everyone
liking them and that was me like I
remember when I came to James
um two and a half years ago and I used
to like think the sun shined out of like
loads of people that treated me badly
when it came to the market and I was
like this person's amazing and James was
like no they're not like what what
they've done for you and I was like oh
yeah actually to be and it's just it's
valuing yourself having real honesty and
authenticity in what you're doing and
don't ever change yourself someone
because the reality is they're probably
not gonna like the version of you that
you're trying to be and they might not
like the version of the you that you are
but it's less exhausting being yourself
and just being you know the person that
you want to be in the market and
spreading that right message that aligns
to your values so the moment that I stop
trying to make everyone like me and
started being a bit more you know
Cutthroat as such I I did better you
know it that was kind of when my career
rocketed was when I stopped wasting time
on people that didn't have time for me
yeah fair enough yeah just started
running your time so how what was what
was at least doing to to only uh build
20 grand a year like because you was in
it for a lot of what because we said
this didn't we like what was going on
like what Looking Back Now what is it
that you was it might have been just
what you just said but what what do you
think you were doing that resulted in
those in that type of performance I was
enjoying the job too much in the sense
of the the social aspect of it like not
the job of recruitment but the job of
building a market I was out there all
the time me it gave me a real good
foundation to meet people which is like
side note key thing about the job like
relationships are everything
um but it just gave me three years of
just networking meeting people
understanding the market like I knew
everybody but I just didn't know how to
make the money match so I'd sit there
and like I could spring people in an
interview with James I was like
springing people off my head like this
person this person was like how have you
built 20 grand I was like
I don't really know what to be fair like
I just didn't I didn't see the money and
I also didn't value money as much I
wasn't as bothered about it whereas you
know I wasn't around people that were
doing that much anyway the the company
as a whole was quite
average so as soon as you put you take
yourself out of that and plop yourself
in an environment where everyone's
really high performing and there's a bit
of like people around you that are
making loads of money you're like I
need to I need to do what they're doing
and it just gave me the kick up the
backside that I needed to just get that
mentality and at the time I had a
manager called Rick when I joined um
Anderson James and I had this
breakthrough and we always talk about it
because it was just iconic and from then
on it was like an understanding that you
know he was the one that was like just
be yourself do what you know but these
are the things that you need to do to
get there and James and Rick have always
been really really supportive of you
know it might not be the right way to do
it but it's my way of doing it and you
know it's kind of works but the the 20
grand thing I can't even get over it now
because I'm like if I'd have joined
James three five years ago and I mean
probably been a million well um what but
so like you know you said around not I
was meeting people building my network
but in relationship with such an
important part so like that's that's
amazing but what was it that you think
that you couldn't quite get right to
like yeah and do deals and like what was
you struggling with in terms of the
matching why didn't that quite work I
just that just wasn't at the Forefront
of my mind so like say for example
you've got a really good it you've got a
job
immediately now in the position I'm in
now if you gave me a job I could give
you three people off the top of my head
I'd be like they're perfect bomb in like
I could do it in five minutes whereas
then like someone gave me a job and I'd
be like I knew hundreds of people I was
like who is that person I just couldn't
do it and I don't know why I couldn't do
it but I wasn't also encouraged to do it
I was very much left on my own sink or
swim you know I was out the office four
days a week meeting people my manager
who I love dearly now he's great
um was running his own desk and building
his own stuff and I just didn't really
have the TLC to get me there which I
think made me realize massively that
your environment is so important to your
own success like as much as everyone's
like you know you want to work for
yourself and I don't I'd be terrible I'd
sit in bed every day I haven't got that
like core motivation inside to run my
own business but I also really
appreciate the people around me that
pushed me forward so when I am feeling a
bit like that they're like common Alicia
like put your together like you
know you know how to do it and then it's
straight back to normal last about a day
whereas before it lasted weeks and I'd
be in a slump of like I don't know what
I'm doing so it is massively the people
around you but I just couldn't pin I
couldn't pin candidates and money
together I just couldn't do it I don't
know what it was it was like a mental
block yeah Fair okay so you mentioned so
let's just get on to the last tournament
years then so with you you mentioned
there with Rick you said right yeah
so the let's talk about that
breakthrough moment you just said
because you said something interesting
in terms of like yeah the message was be
yourself
love that but you said but do these one
two three things what were those things
so when I actually interviewed James and
Rick were like you know it's a big risk
she's only Built 20 grand but I would
take it was a massive like wild card but
then I was like the mentality I'm gonna
prove to everyone that can do it and
then when I went in there
um the thing with Anderson James is that
they're massive on training um which I'd
never had before so I'd been to I've
been left to it and then I'd come here
and it was like right you've got someone
listening in on your calls and I
honestly I remember his name is Baron
and it's I've got PTSD from it he was
like whispering in my ear with one of my
clients I've never spoke to this person
before whispering in my ear telling me I
just I could not I couldn't stop
speaking tell him like what to say yeah
couldn't stop speaking didn't let the
client speak he was trying to tell me
that he wasn't didn't have time for me I
just would not let him say it and I was
like yeah yeah so it was just horrendous
and I remember going into Rick and James
like crying like I can't do it you're
trying to change me and
Rick was like what are you crying for
we're not like go back to what you know
and the key thing for that James always
told me is like meeting everyone is you
know that's the but I'd always done that
anyway so that was really really easy
Rick had always said you know you just
need to understand your market like
mapping your Market out is so important
if you ask me any question about my
market I could answer it like off the
top of my head I can actually I can
answer like which people are here which
people are there how many managers
they've got there how many direct I can
do it all but it's taken me two and a
half years to get there and that's kind
of put me in the position that I'm in
now but the main thing Rick always told
me is that it's so important to
understand your market like if you don't
know your Market you're never going to
make any money you don't know where the
money is so he was always like
you know we're not trying to change your
book we're going to give you all this
information and and pinpoint bits that
you want to take out of it so the key
thing for me was planning that I took
out of the training that we had
um listening you know listening more
than speaking
um that's simple really in it it's a lot
harder to do yeah
excited don't you like I still get
excited to this day about the job but I
think when you start making money
as soon as someone says yeah we'll
interview them you're like yeah
you just need to shut up and just take a
step back and
don't get excited about the little
things you know it's you then put
yourself on a point where you're like
you've already forecasted it and spent
the money in your head so like if like I
don't if I'd have done that when I first
started I'd be thinking oh my God I'm
good about a Bentley and a Birkin bag oh
my God and then the reality is
it's not like because then they drop out
and you're like oh wow a bit of
wasted and it just you can't manage your
emotions very well like Rick's always
taught me manage my emotions James has
always taught me manage my those those
are the key people that have shaped my
career at AJ I've got a new manager now
called Marcus and he's great but I think
that a lot of the foundation of what I
learned was from my time with Rick and
James because they gave me the attention
without micromanaging me which was
massive for me
so I just want to focus on Market
mapping for a sec because that that's
clearly been really quite important yeah
really
really so for anyone listening then
one like when you say understand your
market like what what do you mean by
that exactly so the way I do it you know
it's a bit might be a bit dated let's
say but it's on an Excel spreadsheet so
every single company in my market I've
got on an Excel spreadsheet I've got
every CEO Regional director divisional
director manager I've got everyone on
there so if I ever need so I move it
around as people move and it's quite a
manual way of doing it people might
listen and think that's so pointless and
really hard but it's always worked for
me when companies go into Administration
I highlight them read like it's just
that's how my brain works
um but mapping your Market out so every
company will have so in my market in
particular it'll have like a CEO a
director
um multiple divisional directors I think
it's usually four or five and underneath
them they'll have like managers
underneath them they'll have you know
mid managers and stuff like that so in
any given business it's probably about
about 50 60 people that you can go for
um you know if you're splitting it
divisionally it's completely different
but understanding who the person to
speak to for each thing is so important
because looking long term I mean we've
just started a blue collar division
um across Northwest Yorkshire and the
Midlands
we've never really done it before
um but the fact that we all know our
markets really well on the team has made
it really really easy for people to come
in and go right these are the people
that need to speak to
um but actually understanding where
when you hear of a name that's moving
you automatically know where they've
come from so you can you know there's
your leads or there's a candidate who's
looking or immediate you know it depends
what the situation is but
one person's name leads to so many
different things and I think um I mean
James has always told me about this but
there's a one person knows five people
yeah on average that will be valuable to
you so you need to understand who they
know
um and that's how I'm at my market out
basically I've had contacts in each
company I said who do you know they'd
give me five names give me the numbers
I'd ring them well you know that person
oh yeah yeah straight away walls down
like they're not hiding anything from
you because you've found common ground
and so I met my mark out by finding
people's weaknesses oh I know this
person oh yeah yeah well we did this
this together so I think the main thing
for me and mapping your Market out is
having something in common with someone
whether it be a hobby whether it be a
contact
UM whether it be someone everyone wants
something from you if you're going to go
into a phone call with someone and
you're mapping your Market out and
understanding who works where you need
to build trust with that person
so when you ring them first of all you
know you're not going to ring them go hi
I'm Alicia
um just a quick one who works with you
uh who's your boss like they're gonna be
like go away like why would I tell you
that it's like someone rang me for my
bank details
so you've got to have that same
mentality of like what would what would
you do if someone rang you in that
position or someone was you know
understanding trying to understand your
business it's having a like reality
check of like right okay well what do I
need to give that person so I I'll ring
them and be like hey Paul let's say for
example I was speaking to Barry and
Barry and they're like oh yeah yeah how
is Barry yeah he's great great I just
wanted to get a bit of an understanding
of your business blah blah and that's
how I did it was just being really
relatable and having a laugh with them
like it's not that deep I say it to
everyone I'm like it's not that deep
it's having a conversation with a person
like we all go home have our tea put our
jammies on and go to bed we're the same
that's the reality yeah I love that so I
was going to ask you like okay so if if
that if maybe an old call that Alicia
would do would sound like that or
someone listening right now they're cool
would like they know that the importance
of getting information and understanding
more about that business but the only
way that they feel like they can do it
is by yeah creating that experience that
you just described but now then what
you're saying is because you've done
that upfront work of Market mapping
we're always committing to understanding
where people are at where they're going
and you're asking good quality questions
like who else do you know or
um yeah what challenges do you have or
you know what actually no this person
that had that challenge but now they're
sort of doing this so you're saying now
the calls would sound more like hey
Alicia look I spoke to this person who
said that they know you or like is that
basically what you lean into it's just
like basically using other people it's
it's 100 name dropping is the key
um and people think that you're being
cheeky doing that but if you so I I
speak to a lot of You Know Chief exec
directors and I guarantee the person
that I name drop them to isn't going to
ring them and say oh my God Alicia rang
me and said that she spoke to you they
don't they're not going to do that just
knowing that name is gonna have power so
for me like I'll ring people I'll ring
someone I'll have a conversation like
I've got some great relationships at
like a top level and I always name drop
them and I tell them I'm like I'm gonna
ring that person like yeah do you want
his number I'm like yeah come on
why not like you know you've got to just
be cheeky
and that's the best way to do it like
the worst thing someone's gonna do is
say no that's my like I'm fine with that
like horn rejection is in my blood like
I like it doesn't bother me so you've
got to have a really thick skin like one
thing I think when people get into the
industry is like oh God what if they say
no I'll put the phone down to me like
trust me after five years I've had
enough phones down Potter make of longer
actually dating you know when people
don't want to go on a date with you what
do you do move on to the next
cares like it's not it's not a big deal
and that whole thing I'm saying it oh
it's not that deep
like you know if you ring them and have
a bad call they're not going to go oh my
God two years ago she rang me it was
terrible I'm not gonna say that they're
not even gonna remember they're gonna be
like oh that's a bit we'll see like
I'm like yeah I think we've all got
stories like that oh I've definitely got
um I always remember it like um
it ended up being one of my
um best clients who I did like five
deals with but my first interaction
right with this guy it was so
embarrassing like
um I knew that it was a company that was
like always hiring these things
and during like a BD Sprint or whatever
called his mobile didn't get through
left a voicemail
didn't do a good job of like writing a
note of like that I did that or I didn't
have his number saved or whatever so I
got a call back and like I just couldn't
for the life of me figure out who the
it was because I got a missed call
oh God I know and I was like who is
who's this guy knowing you're on the
phone you're trying to give like a stall
yeah and you're like yeah and then
anyway it was just terrible terrible
call and after afterwards when the call
ended I was like oh my God it was the
guy that I've really I've put on my
dream Client List because I know they're
in my patch they're hiring all the time
and I just made him feel like I can't
even I don't even know who I'm calling
you know the worst thing was I had one
of these the other day and it's someone
that I know really really well as well
he was like but he was like ah you're I
was like hey
the whole thing was just really awkward
nip it must have been like 10 minutes
after he's like during the call he goes
it's Rob and I was like oh God yeah
and I still couldn't picture who it was
but like yeah I think we've all got
those stories and like that happened but
then three months later became like I I
was his guys to do his deals even though
it's like I I get that we all have
stories like that so I don't understand
what you're saying
um so basically advice there then is I
don't think there's anything wrong with
like having a spreadsheet or whatever
it's not old school I think it's like if
if you're listening right now pen and
paper let's just yeah understand so like
if you're listening right now and like
Alicia's saying if you were to get asked
who are the key players in your Market
or like just some key bits high level
stuff around your Market if you're not
able to answer that you're going to
always struggle to um really hit the
numbers that you want to and and just
quickly also like I think although yeah
okay Excel spreadsheet but like that's a
really great visual to be able to like
if you can just go into a document and
just and just like see things you can't
see that on LinkedIn and like
that's that'd be really difficult to
like see all in one place you're seeing
it all in one place so I don't think
that's old school too I think it's just
a smart thing to do and if you're
listening and you don't have anything
like that you just relied on LinkedIn
these things it's different I see a lot
of value in that show me I've got
template
[Laughter]
but I think like one one thing that just
from that like spit off of what you said
is like if someone asks you
a question about the market knowledge is
power like credibility will get you
further than anything in the world you
could not make any money but no point
proven I didn't make any money but I
knew everyone how did I know everyone I
was a name drop it I was like oh no this
person this person knowing people is
your biggest strength and relationships
will be you can do any job I could do
any job in the world and I know that
just because I'm not going to know how
to build relationships like that's all
that all the job is like it's not as
complicated as people make out it's easy
and it's fun you can go out like once
you get to a level where you know
everyone you're out on your lunches and
your golf days or whatever I don't do
golf days
I don't do those I don't do football or
anything like that but that's when it
gets fun hey everyone a real quick one
from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and Source breaker
because you listen to this podcast
you're able to get your hands on
exclusive savings on both of these
award-winning products if you're a
growing recruitment business you have to
check out Vin Cherry who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products so
let's talk about this first year then
because that light is completely like a
different year for you right yeah so
what else are we speaking about Market
mapping speaking about building
relationships knowing people name
dropping these things like what what
else do you think that you did that year
that was totally different to when
Alicia was was doing the numbers before
like what else did you yeah really lean
into become good at in in hindsight
looking back
to be fair it was just work ethic really
I was you know I did five hours on the
phone every day like I was would always
want to be the hardest working person in
the room and I think that
probably the first year I was proving a
point to everybody
I was making a point of being like you
know I do deserve to be here um because
everyone was so everyone was so high
performing and still is
um that I wanted to be in that Circle I
was like I want to be in that Circle
where like you know you're highly rated
and
I think probably the one thing I didn't
do right was doing it for myself
I was doing it for external validation
which I crave on a regular basis I've
got major issues but
um
yeah it was just work ethic you know you
can be a busy fool that's one thing that
you don't want to be but when you
understand the job role and a mapping
your Market out which I already did but
I continued to do you will be the
busiest person in the room
um you know you're always going to be
it's just building relationships with
people so that they can give you the
information that you need so say for
example
you've got a candidate you're on the
phone to him for 10 to 15 minutes you
can find out where he's interviewed who
else he knows five people he works with
who is boss like all these things are
going to be key for you but when you're
just trying to pull as much of that
information as possible it's very easy
to do five hours on the phone four or
five hours three hours whatever it may
be
um now I can do
an hour and a half on the phone a day
and book Seven interviews get like
that's what happens when you kind of do
the hard work at the start but it's that
initial Foundation of you've always just
got to have a really really good work
ethic and no one's going to do it for
you that's that's the harsh reality that
I learned five years ago is that you
know I got given a phone and a laptop
and it was like sink or swim go and
build a market and see what you can do
fair enough I didn't make the business
any money but then I came here got the
right tools to build the house and here
we are living in a mansion like it's
nice like
but I think the difference for me was
just my attitude I wanted to do it you
know I had a real hunger in me that was
like go and get it like you know this is
what your life could look like this will
look like currently I was driving I
remember it so clearly I was dry I had
36 pounds 74 in my bank account when I
joined Anderson James like that was it
that was my first day at 36 pounds 74. I
was driving a Vauxhall Adam red
absolutely battered it was horrendous it
had like a checkered ceiling and my
partner always said he was like he's
like when you flip the car when you
crash you can play chess and it's always
it's just like always stuck with me like
and that was just like and I was so how
would you know I was happy with that
right that would have been absolutely
fine
but then I joined Anderson James
and they were living I was like this is
what I want to be a part of like but
that's what happens when you surround
yourself with high level people
um you are a product of the other you're
an average of the five people around you
or whatever that saying is and I didn't
believe it until I saw it and then I was
like right I need to get into this
circle and that's when you know little
it's little Milestones it's like you get
your first commission she first design a
bag if she first got your first nice car
in those little things keep you going
but you've come I set myself some really
good goals
um and I think having a Clear Vision of
your goals and what you want to do is so
important I I set a goal to do 50k a
quarter that was minimum like I had to
do that and I did it and it's like you
know
this this year I've got to 100K of court
I'm like you know what I mean it's like
you just your goals increase as you
increase but I think having clear goals
is really important
I think also having a great work ethic
is the most important thing you've got
to have something it's it's having
something to work for so you've always
got to have a clear vision of what you
what you want and the worker that comes
from there I mean I've mine comes from a
bit of a different place like you know
but you know we've all got a story
behind us and a reason for going to work
and a reason for wanting to make money
and it's having that a Clear Vision of
that and being like right well I know
what I need to do so let's go get it
yeah I always like the same like you
can't be what you can't see yeah you
know and I think that that's a really
sort of cool part of this story so just
wanted to just focus on one bit of what
you were just saying
because I think actually I when I speak
to a lot of um managers owners and you
always hear this terminology like
get leads
do you know what I mean it's like it's
very classic but what I really liked
about what you said and I think people
early on can sometimes miss this it's
like you can really have the blinkers on
right you've got a job you're working
like that I'll speak to Alicia who sort
of fits the sort of thing and I'm just
I've got my blinks and I'm like could
Alicia do this job I'll answer questions
they should have the right skills the
right background and that's all I'm
focused on yeah but obviously what you
just said in terms of being on the phone
building relationship doing these things
you literally just reeled off like seven
different things that you could get from
that phone call which isn't specific to
just one job to get what I mean 100 so I
think people listen to it like what so
let's just get really granted for a sec
like call it getting leads whatever but
it's getting information information is
power right as you said and we're
building markets we're getting to know
yeah so so
from your perspective
a candidate call or some of the things
that you can get from that Beyond can
Alicia do this job because you just
reeled off a lot so what are always the
typical things that you've got front of
mind that's bigger than this one job if
I'm honest leads are BS okay like like
that like what is a lead is a lead that
they're moving is a lead that the the
interview like what is it like you know
I think it's the getting to know is the
lead okay getting to know yeah like the
GT
um four so they're getting to know
someone it's like so what's the family
life like you know what do they do
outside of the work when they're ringing
you are they walking the dog what dog
have they got like that's it those are
important things because then I think
the daughter's getting married or
whatever like and then you go how was
the wedding when you're next little
things like that okay so getting to know
someone on that personal level is
absolutely massive
um have they interviewed anywhere else
yeah it's important but is what it is
who do they work with do they actually
enjoy their job where are they you know
is there anyone there that you know or
is anyone looking that you know have you
heard anything and these little key bits
of information will give you leads if
you've got the right tuning in your mind
and this is where I think people
forget is the fact that say for example
I spoke to someone the other day you
know I still forget things on the phone
now like I'm not like saying you're not
perfect
you know phone calls and getting to know
people like but my processes I'll always
ring them and then I'll always go and
have a coffee with them or a drink or
you know whatever you want like I'll
always do that because I then get a
deeper level of understanding of who
they are
um but that first initial conversation
you just understanding you know what
their current situation is like who are
they around who do they report into do
they like them and they're automatically
like right do you like your boss oh no
not really either
then then they drop his name there's
your building your Market straight away
so they report into that person you can
add them to the pool of people that they
he works with
um
yeah family stuff's really really
important you've got to understand what
the life looks like outside of the day
job anyway
um but it depends really my
conversations are different on client
and candidate so my client calls I don't
really talk about like I just talk about
them I get an understanding I don't
understand you I want to understand your
team I want to understand what the
business is like do you know the
reputation of the company like I'm
always here to serve hot truths to
clients like I always say to people
about you know what people are saying
about about in the market about you and
they go oh God know what they're saying
uh well it's not very good like you need
to be there to give them that because
you are the expert you know more than
anyone you know what the Market's saying
because you spend four hours a day
speaking to the market so if you hear
about one business that isn't doing very
well you want to ring them and let them
know you know how is there anything that
I can do to help like automatically well
you know what actually we're really
struggling with this okay cool there's a
problem I'm here to solve it so that's
on one side that's that and then on the
other side on the like candidate side it
is just getting to know them and getting
a real understanding of like do they
actually enjoy the job is there anyone
that they work with that they don't like
have they had loads of people leaving
there's immediately you know you've got
there's jobs there because the people
are leaving like it's a spin-off but you
all the key thing is getting to know
them and once you open those that once
that wall of trust goes down you know
they actually trust you they've let you
in it's like a Floodgate they'll tell
you anything but the key thing is that
you've actually got to really value
those people like think of them as your
friends I'm the same with with them as I
am on a night out like I've got the same
banter you know I'm just myself and the
thing is caring about people is really
really important but they know on
straight away if you care or not they're
like is that Jedi Mind Tricks like they
know if you don't care and they know if
you're just after the money just a
transaction yeah yeah and that that's
where you'll you'll fail every time and
that's where I probably failed three
years ago you know was the fact I was
like I wasn't really I wouldn't say I'm
focused on the money but surface level
is like surface level relationship doing
the job like but I think because I built
some great relationships from it it got
me where I am now but at the time it was
never a financial thing so I actually
got to know them on a real level they
were like they were people to me I
didn't want to get I didn't want
anything from them they didn't want
anything from me well you weren't
delivering anything to him mate
talk about soul in the world
you know when you you take that out of
it you actually get real genuine
connection yeah
um and that's probably what I would say
to anyone that's starting out in in
recruitment in any Market you've got to
be genuine you've got to actually care
about it like we've and you know as a
business we've seen people come and go
that you can tell that they don't care
straight away and they don't make any
money right goes hand in hand you've got
to care you've got to actually care
about these people
so what I wanted to just get your
experience on now then is how did you
keep your feet on the ground
because surely like that was a
completely different year for you and I
think it's very easy to sort of talk
about what to do when things are tough
and all that but I think it's just as
important to yeah like share how you
made sure that yeah at least become like
a dip basically like you went from like
being not a big shot to maybe being
feeling like yeah it's a fair question
asked James he gave me a few harsh
realities
like yeah like what what did you learn
about yourself then from going from that
to that because you would earn a lot
more money yeah but how yeah did you
stay grounded you're not let's just keep
it real no I didn't I was an absolute
really yeah your facts like do you know
what I'm not a malicious person and my
heart's always in the right place
but I think it was when you realize how
good you are or how you know how
successful you can be
you start being like well you need to be
that like you start going around
thinking and you know what like James
credit to him and I'm so glad he did it
me and James have had murders about
stuff like this like last year
um that was the year before sorry it was
very much James telling me like look you
don't remember where remember who you
are that's not you
um and all it took was him to have those
harsh conversations but no I didn't stay
grounded at all so what does that look
like you were like just saying like what
you weren't very empathetic or
understanding you I was I was a terrible
person to work with really that's why I
can't manage like I've not got the
patience and I expect everyone to do it
the way that I do it reality is they're
not right no one's the same that's
that's probably where that had to sink
in real quick
um but I went from
you know I had a pretty good job
um prior to working in recruitment I was
a supervisor of a restaurant and I
earned really good money I was about
footballs everywhere it was Mega like
and that's how I learned to talk to
people and have no
judgment on where you come from because
I had the same conversation with them as
I would with someone that's just coming
for a bowl of chips and a glass of Rosie
no judgment here like we all love it
so I think that when I started making
good money again
um but it was probably four times the
amount of money that I'd made doing that
other job I was like oh my God I'm
Beyonce like I'd all of a sudden got in
my head and thought I was this person
that I wasn't
um
I'd say probably the past eight months
have been really really shaping for me
um on a personal level because what I
realized was money doesn't make you
happy really yeah massively like I was
earning the most money I realized I had
no friends I had no one like I had no
genuine like I had my partner but I know
genuine relationships like but I had
this money that I wanted to enjoy
but I didn't have anyone to enjoy it
with and I think that was like a really
big realization for me that like
don't get me wrong like I'm only 24 now
I'm 25 in a month
shout out to me
um big two five
yeah you're no like life expect here but
you're just being real just being honest
in terms of the things that you've had
to learn about yourself I was really
lonely and I think that working in a
sales job when you are young is great
because you can earn great money great
Foundation buy yourself a house buy
yourself a nice car whatever the hell
you want to do that was lonely and I was
sad I used to just like go home and cry
like and that's like the reality of it
is the fact that you know everyone wants
money but when you've got it you know
unless you've got yourself and you know
yourself really well and you're really
happy and you've got a good life you're
not going to enjoy it so I was rich and
miserable and you know didn't have real
friends to enjoy it with and you know
I'd like my family yeah we were great
did some nice things but you want your
friends don't you want to like and I
think I've worked really hard last year
on building a really solid circle around
me that of people actually support me
because a lot of the times it's jealousy
you know yeah I'm 24 like earning really
really good money loads of my friends
are in like you know just normal admin
jobs which I love like I loved my admin
job when I had it like it's just chill
they don't want that I love the high
pressure environment some people don't
like you know but you go in like we'd go
to America all the time like Partners
there like we you know we we do stuff
like that and I couldn't do it with
anyone because they were like oh no I
don't really have the money but you
realize that when those people see
you've got money they're like oh I want
to go out for dinner but I've got no
money oh it's fine I'll pay
why like Moog like why why would I do
that unless you actually do it back I'm
not doing it like and I think that was
probably the reality that I was really
lonely and I was really sad and then
last year
I worked really hard to like and that
was my best year last year but I was
having the most fun I had the best year
of my life last year yeah that's my girl
yeah it was just fun like it was just
that I enjoyed and I did it right but
yeah money does not make you happy facts
it's nice yeah no yeah no I feel no I
really appreciate you sharing that and
and you being honest
because yeah I think let's be honest
like for me for me personally what I can
speak about is money for me is it is
about options like the main thing that I
get excited about so like if I was to
write I wanna earn a hundred grand and I
was to look at that goal that would make
me feel nothing yeah
so for me what I've had to continually
get better at and understand is okay so
if I make 100 Grand what does that
actually mean well it means that uh me
and Jess gonna be able to get the home
and the like and like take steps towards
the life they want to build that that
means something I want to be able to
help my parents buy a place in Morocco
or whatever which is their dream like
that you have to work that out do you
know what I mean so I've definitely been
on on that Journey but you are right in
terms of yeah you might have the most
amount of money that you have in your
bank account but if you just feel like
you've got no connection with anyone on
these things that's that's a
tough position to be in yeah massively
and I think it all stems back from
having those clear goals like my goal
was Financial so when I had that money
how's that what do I do with it now like
you know I'd set this goal of having
this financial goal but I was like I
don't really know what to do with it
whereas last year my goal was to travel
right and boy did I travel I had the
best time and it's like I shared some
amazing memories with people and you
know I think
James is harping on about James but
James is always like you know it's nice
having designer things but that isn't
like that isn't the be-all and end-all
so the first year that I made money I
was head to toe in designer I was living
I was like look at me Louis Vuitton like
I like a knob like that's not like you
had something to do like trying to
Showcase something who was I doing it
for like that's what I was saying about
last year I did it for me whereas the
year before I was doing it for everyone
else and you know the designer bags were
thin literally like the plastic we're
spending like I know I've got nothing to
say because I've got one still but like
it it wears them you know the joy of
getting a designer bag like yeah you
have to get one like that's a fact like
in your life you need to just get one
just as a thing but like you know
getting them once and once a quarter
because or once a month because you've
got good money is it realistic and it's
also not a cool thing to do
so let so a lot so let's talk about like
yeah last year then I've been talking
about that and like I said I really
appreciate you being um honest with us
here so what so there's one thing and
I'll just send this to the previous guy
because he'd be in a similar Journey
like there's one thing achieving that
top Bill of status but then I don't know
what you feel like but a lot of people
that I've interviewed they've sort of
felt like retaining it is like if not
harder basically yeah it is so what did
sort of again what what I'd love to ask
you is like what did you have top of
Mind where where Did you sort of try and
get better in in the one percents in
terms of going from 240 to 360. what do
you do anything differently what did you
double down on so
are you planning for me with k
so I've started something
okay it's life-changing talk to us no
credits to it someone on Tick Tock
showed at me
um it's basically where you break your
year down into 12 weeks so you focus on
quarters instead of the year um now it's
great when you work in recruitment
because
12 weeks flies by but it's so important
you know a lot can happen in 12 weeks so
you basically how do I describe it so
you start off with your goals what do
you want to achieve for the year for the
for the 12 weeks okay for 12 weeks you
have a year goal you know what your year
goal is but you break it down into a
smaller one that's what I was going to
say yeah
12 weeks so in that 12 weeks you break
it up into say Jun Feb March so what do
you need to do what three things do you
need to do to achieve that goal just
three three four you can do our movement
how many many goals you've got you can
mine's three so I always work in threes
I don't know what it is with me like a
one in three ratio of them getting
placed
um
break it up into three so
what do you need to do to do that three
things so what every daily what daily
tasks do you need to do to achieve that
goal so every month is different so say
for example I'll use one of my things so
mine would be do a hundred grand in a
quarter okay
so what then break it up into three
goals how many placements do I need to
do to do that so I think mine worked out
it was like 12 placements to do that
so then that's done so we need to do 12
placements what do I need to do to do
those 12 placements well daily so I need
to send nine CVS a week I need to be
have five interviews a week so I broke
it down really really nitty-gritty and
that was my kpis but the 12 week year is
really important because
you're not worrying about the year
um you know when I think one thing with
newer recruiters is that they Panic well
I've got loads of time you haven't trust
me like and it changes by the day it's a
roller coaster emotions but breaking it
down into a 12-week year will just give
you so much more manageable time because
you're not worrying about what's
happening for the rest of the year you
don't care if the Market's taking a turn
in July you're focused on January
February March because if and then if
you do those things it plays out anyway
exactly um and you can wrap it can be
the same every you know every
managing that is really really important
so say for example January February
March is a key time for me to meet
clients and candidates
so I'll Target myself on 10 week into 10
10 Wheaton's 10 meetings a week I just
need to hit that that's like so I want
to meet XMR people so if your target is
I want to meet
half the market it was going to be hard
because the Market's big but how how do
you do that well I need to meet this
many people a week well how are you
going to meet that many people a week I
need to make this many phone calls you
know some of them are going to drop out
so you need to make more than it's just
it's having it in a really manageable
like I need manageable things for me you
know that it really breaks it down and
then how do you hold yourself
accountable every week are you reviewing
so yeah I've got a spreadsheet shark
yeah that's fine that is basically
um I keep track of everything that I'm
doing okay
um and on there is a template for this
on a thing called notion so yeah I use
notion yeah notion's amazing
um there is a 12-week year thing on
notion oh really I can send you the
templates it's so good
um which basically will hold you really
accountable because you track it every
day haven't done that no like I I
don't to be honest I wouldn't real two
years ago I wouldn't let myself leave
the office on a Friday if I hadn't have
done it now I'm a bit less lenient
because I know how to get if something
drops out or I don't do so
[Music]
but I wish I did 12-week year when I
started recruitment that was just it was
it's so good like it just holds you
really really accountable but it also
keeps it quite manageable for you you
know it's like 12 weeks what like you
know when you actually realize what you
can do in 12 weeks it gives you the
biggest level of confidence like you're
like oh my God like I've met
100 people or I've done this or I've
done like you you really back yourself
even more but it that would be a really
really key thing that anyone that like
wants to know about that like it's in
Holland like it's amazing love it all
right so as we come to an end here then
I wanted to ask you because I know it's
something you're passionate about we've
spoken about organization building
relationships so I'm just going to say
this because what I I don't you can tell
me what you think right yeah yeah but
like when when I hear people on podcasts
um and even just like content that I
consume right
and basically so because Alicia is a
woman that works in construction yeah
like for from where I sit in I feel like
a lot of people are good at them putting
you in like a box and be like because
you're a woman in construction it's an
eyelashes they say yeah whatever yeah
like you that mean that must mean that
you experiencing certain things right
yeah so my question isn't that it's just
like women working in your Market as a
as a female what has that experience
been like rather than me being like Oh
has it been challenging for you because
you're a woman in construction I don't
think that's the right way to approach
these things but you share with you
share with us what your experience has
been is so outdated like it depends who
you are if you're a sap and you let
people do it then you're like that's on
you that's not on anyone else like at
the end of the day you know yeah it does
happen but you are in control of that
like you need to tell like if someone
said to me right
I was like I said something a bit
different I'd be like you all right like
I'd make them feel bad about I'd
embarrass them you just got to school
these people like but I think it's
because I backed myself a little bit
more where I'm just like I'm not gonna
let people
walk or if I want to flirt with someone
I'll flirt with them like it's not it's
not the end of like you know you have
that bantered only where it's like I've
got a few of my clients that like we
just have a laugh together like it's
dead friendly Dead funny
um but it's always professional like
there's some people that cross out like
one thing that I would never do is cross
that professional like level for me like
I'm that's like totally out of character
like it's just not my not how I work
some people do some people don't that's
fine like no judgment on anyone
um but for me I'll always flip it back
what do you mean like does your wife
know you're saying that to me
does your wife and kids know that you
think that right you know that you just
gotta you've got him but it is it is
tough don't get me wrong like there are
a few people it's a lot more educated
now the industry and construction like
so you have found it off yeah at the
start I did because I didn't back myself
and I'd let people just like say the
most horrendous things to me like it but
looking now it's not where it was and I
think as well
you are
how do I describe this now
you allow if you'll allow it to happen
it'll happen right and it is a tough
industry because it's very male
dominated but I'm massive on women in
construction you know I've placed a lot
of females into the biz into businesses
um and encourage a lot of people that
are female to get into the business like
and it is hard because I think people
still have this preconception it's not
what it used to be even five six years
ago it was but it's not that now like
people there are people a lot um tougher
on within businesses so it isn't like
that
um however you know you still get the
odd person it's not like just who cares
like just embarrass them
all right it's the best thing to do is
feel oh shut up like weirdo like you're
right but that's the best way to do it
whereas some people I know feel quite
intimidated by it um but you've got to
set your stall out and you know you'd be
like don't speak to me like that so
what's the advice for people then okay
so if I'm listening right now if I'm
listening right now I'm female working
the construction thing I'm yeah like
what is there any advice that you have
for me but you are in control of the
level of banter if you don't like it
just say you don't like like I'm very
very vocal about how I feel about things
as you probably know like I'm not afraid
to tell people what I think used to be
now I'm not when I was afraid of what
people thought of me and tried to make
everyone like me if you put someone in
their spot and they don't like it you
don't want to work with that person
that's that's they're not the type of
people that you want to involve yourself
with you know if there's people that are
worried about getting into the industry
or worried about what people will say
when they do say it say Oh no you're all
right see like never speak to them again
that's fine like you've embarrassed them
so they probably don't want to speak to
you either but you also don't want to
associate with those types of people
they're not professional you're not
actually going to get anything out of
them because they'll string you along on
like a little like one of them hoping
that you're gonna like go and you know
flirt with them like you're not so you
don't need them him like it doesn't
matter
um but I think people people do feel a
level of pressure when they are new to
the industry for everyone to like them
and to go along with it and to be like
oh yeah like no
no just like put them in their place but
that's taken a bit of time for you to
like yeah I'm confident but I think that
it's very easy when you get into do that
like don't worry about what people think
about you that that's all that's been
that seems to have been like this like
constant things he just hadn't done that
though yeah it is but I think that
having respect for yourself and knowing
that you are a professional person
backing yourself in the sense of you
know you're credible you know what
you're talking about even if you don't
you do you know you whatever like I was
I probably don't know I'm talking about
hard but I'll say I do
um but just backing yourself in the
sense that your values aren't that like
you don't have to lower yourself to
anyone else's standard like you're there
to do a job you're not there to be you
know a like Dolly trolley or whatever I
don't know what a word is but like you
know you're not there to be like an eye
candy for someone like you're you're
professional and at the moment that you
set that stall out and do that people
have so much more respect for you yeah
yeah
well look absolutely love that
conversation it's been great uh nothing
short of authentic which brings us back
to the first point which look that's
that's what I'm all about that's that's
how I roll I think look credit to you uh
I think that's
like your story is what's so cool about
art industry I think like if you're
someone that's willing to work hard
learn look at yourself in the mirror
then there's there's no reason why you
aren't able to achieve the the life or
the goals that that you want you know so
I think kudos to you to turning around
um it obviously hasn't been easy you've
had to have some tough conversations
you've had to have people be honest with
you and again that that takes courage to
take that on you know so uh massive
thank you for coming on the Pod thanks
for having me absolutely loved it thank
you so much for listening to the episode
I hope you enjoyed it and got value from
the conversation if you did enjoy it
please don't forget to like share and
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
episode
all right